We said that to implement locks easily, we need
atomic instructions that are going to both read and write
memory. There are three main types of such instructions.
The first type is an atomic exchange instruction, something like
this. The parameters for this instruction look like the
parameters for a load or a store, but what an
exchange does, it does both a load and a store
at the same time, so that it swaps the content
of R1 with the contents of the memory location
that it, the address is. So a load would
read this and put it in R1. A store would take what's in R1 and put it here.
An exchange swaps the contents of the two. So
the register gets what was in the memory location.
And the memory location gets what was in the
register. If we have an atomic exchange, what we can
do is put 1 into R1 and then repeatedly as long as R1 is equal to 1, exchange
R1 with that lock variable. So this is the idea, R1 being 1, we are exchanging
our R1 with a lock variable. We start out with 1 in R1. When we swap them,
if the memory location for the lock had
a zero, it becomes one in the same instruction
that gets us a zero. If we do get a zero, we exit this loop. And the lock
variable has become 1. If however the lock was already occupied, then we swap 1
with 1. R1 stays 1, so we keep looping. So until we succeed in obtaining a zero,
we will loop here just as before, but
also as we're getting our zero, we are automatically
setting the lock variable to one, so nobody else
can also observe a zero. Pretty much if we
get a zero in our R1, that means that
everybody who'll try to do this at the same time
will get our one. If somebody else did this
before us, then we would be getting their one in
our R1. So the fact that we are reading
zero here means that we are the ones who acquired
the lock. So atomic exchange gives us this read
and write at the same time behavior that we
want to implement our locks and as you can
see the lock function can now be very simple. The
drawback of the atomic exchange operation is that it
keeps writing to the memory location all the time, even
while the lock is busy, while the lock has
been locked by somebody else. So as long as we're
doing this, we will be these writes even though we
are just getting a one all the time. So the
second main type of atomic instructions is a whole family
of things that can be classified as test and then
write. So, the idea is that we test the location
and if it satisfies some conditions, then we are going to
write, but we don't write all the time. So let's
say we have some sort of a test and store
instruction which behaves like this. We read the
memory location that we are addressing, and if that
location is zero then we store R1 into it.
And in that case, R1 becomes 1, but if
the location wasn't o ,then we don't store
anything to that location. We just return a 0.
So the idea here is that we are testing the whether the lock is free. If it is
free, then we try to write a 1 in it. If it's not free, then we simply continue.
There is no point in trying to write to
a lock that we know is not free. So we're
avoiding the writes that happen in the exchange, while
the lock is actually not free. So this behaves
very similarly to the exchange, except that it only
does the write if the lock has the unlock state.